nous entendons ce matin en application
du 5e alinéa de l'article 13 de la
Constitution monsieur thbo guiloui
candidat proposé par le Pr de la
République à la direction générale de
Pôle
Emploi cette audition sera suivie d'un
vote je vous le rappel sur cette
candidature pour lequel vous le savez
aucune délégation ne sera
admise je vous précise que cette
audition fait l'objet d'une captation
vidéo retransmise en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat et sera consultable en
vidéo à la demand
conformément au principe de publicité
prévu par la loi du 23 juillet
2010 je vous rappelle que pour l'emploi
est un établissement public à caractère
administratif chargé notamment de
prospecter le marché du travail
d'accueillir et d'accompagner les
demandeurs d'emploi de tenir la liste
des demandeurs d'emploi d'assurer le
service de la location d'assurance
chômage et si nécessaire de décider de
la suppression du revenu de remplacement
et du prononcé de la pénalité
administrative le projet de loi pour le
plein emploi définitivement adopté par
le Parlement le 14 novembre 2023 prévoit
de rebaptiser l'opérateur qui sera
dénommé France travail de faire évoluer
ses missions afin de l'inscrire au sein
d'un réseau pour l'emploi qui regroupera
l'ensemble des acteurs de l'emploi en
France et au niveau local le directeur
général est nommé pour une durée de 3
ans son mandat est
renouvelable monsieur guilouis je vous
propose donc de débuter cette édition
par un propos liminaire dans lequel vous
nous exposerez votre parcours
professionnel
en particulier les actions que vous avez
conduite lors de votre mission pour la
transformation de Pôle emploi mais
également vos motivations et vos projets
pour l'avenir et ensuite nous donnerons
la parole aux commissaires qui le
souhaitent qui seront amenés à vous
solliciter voilà monsieur guiloui je
vous donne la
parole monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs c'est un honneur
pour moi de me présenter devant vous en
tant que candidat à la direction
générale de P emploi cette audition
constitue une occasion de détailler avec
vous les enjeux les priorités et les
défis pour Paul emploi qui écrira
bientôt une nouvelle page de son
histoire avec l'avènement de France
travail on mautorisant à défendre ma
candidature devant vous mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs le gouvernement
m'honore de sa confiance et par cette
audition je souhaite désormais
solliciter la vôtre afin de me voir
confier cette mission au service de
l'objectif du plein emploi derrière
cette marque de confiance il me semble
que le gouvernement réaffirme sa volonté
de mettre en œuvre les propositions du
projet France travail vous le savez nous
ont fait l'objet d'une vaste
concertation avec tous les acteurs de
l'emploi de l'insertion et de la
formation puis d'un débat parlementaire
de qualité jusqu'à l'adoption définitive
du projet de loi plein emploi en cela il
s'agit aussi de la validation d'une
méthode celle de la coconstruction que
j'ai toujours défendu et qui me paraît
essentiel pour parvenir à transformer
PUL emploi en France travail et pour
assurer une meilleure coopération entre
les acteurs enfin pour ma part cette
candidature c'est aussi une chance
unique de poursuivre mon engagement
personnel auquel je consacre toute mon
énergie depuis 25 ans permettre l'accès
du plus grand nombre à l'autonomie et à
la dignité par le travail si vous le
permettez avant de détailler ma vision
des priorités pour France travail puis
de me soumettre à vos différentes
questions je vous propose donc de
revenir brièvement sur mon parcours
d'abord j'ai consacré plus de 20 ans de
ma vie à l'entrepreneuriat social avec
toujours la même aspiration celle de
faire en sorte que chaque personne
puisse retrouver un emploi en effet je
crois fondamentalement dans
l'émancipation par le travail et dans le
rôle et la responsabilité des
entreprises pour la favoriser c'est ce
rôle social et sociétal des entreprises
que j'ai aussi incarné dans mes
différents engagement au services
bénévoles d'association comme maemus
action prévention sport ou les apprentis
d'ôuteuil en fondant les structures
d'insertion Sport Sans Frontières puis
atelers sans frontières ou encore en
développant pendant 15 ans le groupe
aress aujourd'hui devenu premier acteur
de l'insertion par activité économique
en Île-de-France avec près de 3000
personnes accompagnées par an depuis 5
ans j'ai poursu suivi cette même
ambition en me consacrant aux politiques
publiques d'abord au service de la
ministre Murielle pénicot pour porter le
pacte d'ambition pour l'insertion par
l'activité économique ou organiser
l'évolution du rôle des entreprises
adaptées avec notamment la création du
CDD trempelin dont l'expérimentation
vient d'être pérénisé grâce à vous à
l'occasion du projet de loi plein emploi
puis je vrer auprès de Madame Élisabeth
de la ministre Élisabeth borne pour
déployer le plan un jeune une solution
qui a contribué à faire baisser
significativement le taux de chômage des
jeunes malgré les effets de la crise
sanitaire ce plan était en quelque sorte
déjà préfigurateur de la démarche France
travail mobiliser largement acteurs
publics associations et entreprises et
travailler ensemble au service d'une
cause partagée ce plan c'est pour moi la
preuve que toutes les forces du pays
bien coordonnées et bien orienté peuvent
produire des résultats tangibles et
concrets pour nos concitoyens et la
dynamique de l'emploi une illustration
de cette forte mobilisation c'est aussi
celle des entreprises que je porte avec
la communauté des entre ise s'engage
lancé par le Président de la République
et que je co-préside avec Sylvie Giano
qui est la directrice générale de Dalin
elle regroupe déjà plus de 70000
entreprises partout sur le territoire de
la TPE au grand groupe qui s'engage
concrètement en faveur de l'inclusion
des jeunes des personnes en situation
d'handicap des personnes placées sous
main de justice des personnes réfugiées
et tant d'autres enfin il y a un peu
plus d'un an le ministre du Travail du
plein emploi et de l'insertion Olivier
duofte que je remercie pour sa confiance
m'a confié une nouvelle mission celle de
préfigurer France travail par des
propositions concrètes pour contribuer à
l'objectif du plein emploi d'ici 2027
c'est ainsi que pendant 9 mois avec mon
équipe nous avons mené une large mission
de concertation pour formaliser un plan
d'action partagé et structuré autour de
10 principes clés et 99 propositions
opérationnelles que nous avons remis au
gouvernement aux partenaires sociaux et
à l'ensemble des parties prenantes
associées en avril dernier au-delà des
propositions France travail c'est aussi
une méthode celle de partir des idées
qui marchent sur le terrain celle aussi
de la coconstruction avec l'exigence de
remettre l'usager au centre nous avons
donc mené plus d'une centaine de
rencontres territoriales autant
d'échanges bilatéraux ainsi que des
dizaines d'ateliers collectifs pour
aboutir à des propositions qui pour la
plupart ont fait leur preuve et
répondent aux besoins des personnes des
entreprises et de celles et ceux qui les
accompagnent France travail c'est aussi
un Paris celui de la coopération et de
l'investissement social plutôt que d'un
anè exercice de mécano institutionnel
l'ambition de France travail c'est avant
tout la meilleure coopération entre
acteurs principe fondateur que vous avez
validé par l'adoption du projet de loi
pour le plein emploi j'en profite pour
vous remercier pour ces débats sincères
parfois animé mais toujours constructif
dans le cadre de l'examen du texte au
Parlement et lors des concertations
associées je salue là aussi la la la
rapporteuse du texte il me semble que ce
débat a permis d'améliorer le projet à
bien des égards
on dit
pas ou la rapporteur pardonnez-moi mais
bon je je
féminise je pense notamment à la place
confortée des partenaires sociaux dans
la gouvernance à la meilleure prise en
compte des situations individuel dans
l'accompagnement proposé par le contrat
d'engagement par exemple la situation
des prdents ou à la compétence donnée au
Cap Emploi pour orienter les publics
qu'ils accueillent ou encore aux
précisions que vous avez apporté sur les
jeunes accompagnés par les missions
locales et concerné par l'inscription à
France travail le texte adopté reconnaît
d'ailleurs plus clairement la place des
missions locales dans la dans la mise en
œuvre de la réforme et je m'en réjouis
parce que je sais le précieux travail
qu'elle réalise sur le terrain c'est
d'ailleurs pourquoi je suis attaché à
renforcer les coopérations avec elle
comme celle avec Cap emploi et tous les
acteurs de l'insertion je pense
notamment évidemment au plis aux maisons
de l'emploi puisqu'on a aussi beaucoup
travaillé avec la la sénatrice puissa
c'est la première des conditions si nous
nous souhaitons parvenir à construire un
accompagnement adapté à chacun vers
l'emploi c'est aussi en nous organisant
mieux autour des bassins d'emploi et en
assurant un pilotage plus collectif des
actions que nous pourrons répondre plus
efficacement aux besoins des personnes
comme aux attentes des entreprises et
tout particulièrement cell des TPE et
PME fort de ces quelques convictions si
vous m'accordez votre confiance ma
prochaine mission pourrait donc être
d'assurer la direction de PUL emploi qui
deviendra France travail dès le 1er
janvier et qui sera doté de nouvelles
missions pour le compte de tous avec
l'ambition de créer les conditions de la
collaboration et de l'efficacité
collective avant de vous préciser mes
priorités pour France travail je tiens
d'abord à saluer l'actuel directeur
général Jean Basser qui a largement
contribué à transformer la maison pour
emploi pendant ces 12 années de mandat
et avec qui j'ai eu le plaisir d' vrer
ces dernières années dans la mise en
œuvre de nombreuses actions son héritage
est immense et constitue le socle solide
sur lequel nous pouvons bâtir France
travail une organisation solide et
territorialisée la mise en place des
parcours d'accompagnement intensifs et
individualisés à l'instar du contrat
d'engagement jeune le développement de
la relation avec les entreprises avec la
constitution d'un réseau de près de 5700
conseillers ou encore la transformation
digitale des services sont autant de
fondations solides pour France travail
au-delà de son action ce sont aussi des
valeurs des valeurs d'intégrité de
professionnalisme et d'engagement qu'il
a su partager avec les 55000
collaborateurs de pôul emploi dont je
tiens à saluer l'implication sans faille
au quotidien pour les demandeurs
d'emploi comme pour les entreprises
je tiens aussi à remercier l'ensemble
des membres du conseil d'administration
qui m'ont fait l'honneur de leur
confiance quant à ma candidature pour
mettre en œuvre l'ambition de France
travail je vois donc trois grandes
priorités apporter comme je l'ai déjà
exprimé la première d'entre elles c'est
naturellement d'engager la
transformation de l'opérateur pour
répondre à ces nouvelles missions
inscrites dans la loi avec la meilleure
efficacité possible en premier lieu avec
ses partenaire et en accord avec sa
gouvernance France travail devra
conduire les travaux relatifs aux
évolutions législatives qui entre en
vigueur au 1er janvier 2025 notamment le
fait d'inscrire plus largement les
personnes dépourvues d'emploi à France
travail dans le souci de ne laisser
personne sur le bord de la route les
orienter rapidement vers le bon référent
d'accompagnement pour définir ensemble
un contrat d'engagement et permettre un
parcours adapté assurant un retour le
plus rapide possible à l'emploi il
conviendra aussi de mettre en place la
nouvelle sanction dite de suspension et
remobilisation et les nouvelles
modalités de contrôle ces différentes
dispositions supposeront un travail
important dans les prochains mois avec
les partenaires du réseau pour l'emploi
notamment la CNAF les conseils
départementaux les missions locales Cap
emploi et tous les acteurs qui
contribuent à l'insertion dans les
territoires France travail devra aussi
assurer la mise en œuvre opérationnelle
des missions pour le compte de tous la
fonction d'appui de l'opérateur
premièrement à la mise en place des
gouvernances du réseau pour l'emploi il
s'agit ici de l'opérationnalisation et
de la déconcentration des décision avec
notamment la mise en place des comités
locaux du réseau pour l'emploi et le
travail de feuille de route par partagé
au niveau des bassins d'emploi pour
l'opérateur il s'agira en particulier de
renforcer la culture du pilotage au
résultats avec la capacité donné à
l'ensemble des acteurs et des
gouvernances de prendre de meilleures
décisions basées sur des résultats
factuels et mesurés c'est la logique que
nous poursuivons déjà avec les
expérimentations et qu'il nous faudra
faire monter en puissance je crois
fondamentalement que les décisions
doivent se prendre au plus proche du
terrain et des usagers deuxièmement le
développement d'un système d'information
plateforme et des communs numériques
nécessaire pour simplifier le quotidien
des professionnels des entreprises et
des demandeurs d'emploi c'est aussi un
meilleur partage de la donnée pour tenir
la promesse du dit-lenous une fois
supprimer progressivement les charges de
reporting et permettre un pilotage de
l'ensemble sur la base d'indicateurs
partagés aussi France travail devra
accélérer ses investigations sur
l'intelligence artificielle qui risque
de bouleverser nos manières de
travailler troisièmement il nous
appartient de favoriser
l'interconnaissance entre les
professionnels valoriser leur capacité
d'initiative et d'innovation et
accompagner la montée en compétence de
chacun grâce à la mise en œuvre de
l'Académie France travail c'est une
condition nécessaire pour parvenir à
mener les grandes transformation que nos
ambitions appellent j'ai confiance dans
l'engagement de tous ces agents et je
tiens donc à prendre soin de ceux qui
prennent soin car c'est par eux que nous
réussirons deuxième grande priorité dans
une logique d'efficacité et face à une
conjoncture incertaine nous devons mener
avec la gouvernance de France travail
les actions qui présentent le plus haut
rendement en terme de création d'emploi
il s'agit d'abord de de déployer
progressivement les actions d'aller vert
et l'accompagnement intensif des
personnes qui en ont besoin c'est
notamment la philosophie des 15 heures
d'activité au moins les premiers retours
du contrat d'engagement jeune nous
montrent déjà que cela a des effets
bénéfiques sur le retour à l'emploi
comme vous l'avez rappelé lors des
débats au Sénat puis en CMP cette
intensification de l'accompagnement doit
se faire en préservant la logique de
personnalisation des parcours et en
s'adaptant aux situations de chacun
comme le précise la dernière version du
texte il convient aussi de prospecter et
d'accompagner davantage les entreprises
notamment les TPE France travail doit
être demain le partenaire RH de
l'ensemble des entreprises qui recrutent
et non plus seulement des entreprises
qui le sollicitent c'est l'un des
principes du rapport de préfiguration de
France travail aider les employeurs à
recruter plus simplement et plus
rapidement pour s'ouvrir à tous les
talents possibles mieux pour voir à tous
les besoins notamment dans les secteurs
en tension et créer Infiné plus
d'emplois durable dans le même esprit il
faudra poursuivre le travail au côté des
conseils Ré
et des branches professionnelles pour
relever le défi des compétences
d'aujourd'hui et de demain en se
mobilisant pour proposer aux demandeurs
d'emploi des formations plus efficace
pour leur retour à l'emploi je crois par
exemple qu'un dispositif comme la
préparation opérationnelle à l'emploi
dont les effets sur le retour à l'emploi
sont prouvés mériterait d'être simplifié
et accéléré sur ces différents objets
nous avons un enjeu de pilotage et de
montter en puissance itérative c'est
d'ailleurs dans cette logique nous
travaillons dans le cadre de la
préfiguration avec les conseils
départementaux sur la accompagnement des
bénéficiaires du RSA ce sont déjà 18
territoires pilotes qui sont entrés dans
l'expérimentation avec plus de 12000
bénéficiaires du RSA en parcours
d'accompagnement rénové et des premiers
signes de satisfaction une prise en
charge beaucoup plus rapide un
diagnostic socio-professionnel partagé
qui permet une meilleure prise en compte
de la situation des personnes et une
accélération de l'accompagnement vers
l'emploi des données de pilotage
accessibles à tous en temps réel
permettent un suivi au plus proche du
terrain des plans d'action par AG de la
mobilisation des entreprises du
territoire également nous travaillons
aussi avec les partenaires sociaux les
élus locaux et les régions dont se ont
d'ors et déjà signé des protocoles de
préfiguration de France travail
déclinant des feuilles de route
opérationnelles autour des enjeux de
formation professionnelle de service aux
entreprises et d'adaptation aux besoins
économiques et sociaux de chaque bassin
de vie nous devrons mener des évaluation
d'étapes au fil de nos transformations
et en tenir compte dans le déploiement
des différentes initiatives de la
réforme et de la priorisation des moyens
budgétaires qui seront affectés je tiens
à cet égard à pouvoir rendre des comptes
régulièrement devant vous monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs et selon les modalités que
vous voudrez bien m'indiquer enfin 3ème
et dernière grande priorité il me semble
que vous que nous pouvons gagner en
efficacité sur l'indemnisation P emploi
verse pour le compte de l'État et des
partenaires sociaux gestionnaire du
régime d'assurance chômage un ensemble
d'allocations appuyé sur une
réglementation complexe et qui évolue
régulièrement c'est la mission
fondamentale celle qui sécurise les
demandeurs d'emploi sur leurs ressources
pour qu'ils se tourne en confiance vers
le retour à l'emploi deux défis devront
je le crois être relevés par France
travail lutter plus fortement encore
contre les versements à tort des
allocations lutter aussi contre le non
recours au droit en simplifiant les
demandes d'allocation et en accélérant
les échanges de données entre
administration pour faire vivre là aussi
le principe du dites-le nous une fois
voilà Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs les quelques grandes priorités
que je tenais à mettre en avant dans ce
propos liminaire et qu'il conviendra de
décler
avec la gouvernance de France travail et
l'ensemble de ses collaborateurs et de
ses partenaires j'ai eu l'honneur de
travailler à la préfiguration de France
travail à vos côtés vous savez les
convictions fortes qui sont les miennes
pour servir cette belle et grande
mission et je suis donc très heureux de
pouvoir en discuter avec vous je me
tiens donc à votre disposition pour
l'ensemble des questions que vous
souhaitez me
poser merci Monsieur guiloui pour cette
intervention alors nous allons procéder
donc à un certain nombre de de collègues
souhaitent vous poser des questions je
vais commencer en tant que rapporteur de
cette audition puis ensuite je donnerai
la parole à Pascal grunny et Frédéric
puissa nos rapporteurs sur les travaux
que nous avons menés puis ensuite à
l'ensemble des sénateurs voilà alors
Monsieur guiloui première question dans
votre rapport de préfiguration vous avez
estimé qu'il serait nécessaire de
mobiliser de l'ordre de 2,3 avec 2,7
milliards d'euros de financement cumulés
sur la période
2024226 pour réformer le service public
de l'emploi et accompagner l'ensemble
des demandeurs d'emploi au sein de cette
enveloppe avez-vous un chiffrage précis
du coût pour Pôle emploi des
transformations à venir deème point la
réforme de Pôle emploi en France travail
a aussi pour ambition de renforcer
l'offre des services aux entreprises
même si cet aspect ne relevait pas
directement de la loi pour le plein
emploi quels sont selon vous les
chantiers prioritaires pour renforcer
les liens entre pour l'emploi et les
employeurs et dernière question quel
bilan faites-vous du rapprochement
depuis 2021 des CAP EMPLOI et de Pôle
Emploi sujet qui me tient particuliement
ACC cœur voilà donc je vous laisse
répondre à ces premières questions et
ensuite la parole à nos deux
rapporteurs euh merci merci monsieur le
Président sur le sur le les les moyens
sur les 2,3 2,7 milliards effectivement
sur une montée en puissance progressive
2024 2000 2026 au gré des apprentissages
euh il y a une une trajectoire qui a été
annoncée par le gouvernement et par le
ministre du Travail qui était validé sur
300 millions en 2024 500 millions en
2000 25 750 millions d'euros en 2026 et
je rajouterai en 2027 1 milliard d'euros
quand on sera en en année pleinement
pleinement lancé si si si jeose dire
au-delà de ces moyens j'attire
l'attention sur le fait que il est
important d'avoir en tête que on
renouvelle aussi le plan
d'investissement dans les compétences
qui était aussi une attention je crois
que nous avions en partage et que
j'avais relayé dans le rapport France
travail 3,9 milliards d'euros seront
apportés au côté des de effort des
régions pour renforcer la possibilité de
de pouvoir former les demandeurs
d'emploi et de répondre aux besoins des
entreprises et puis le le le le le
troisème élément c'est le financement
des départements dans le casadre de la
contractualisation France travail et
donc on avait on était dans une phase
d'expérimentation en 2023 avec de
l'ordre de 20 million d'euros sur les 18
territoires pilotes on va mettre en
place le ministre du travail avec les
départements de France en train de
finaliser la mise en œuvre de la
contractualis a pour tous les
départements de France dès 2024 avec une
enveloppe de 170 millions d'euros qui à
la fois va accompagner chaque
département à préparer la mise en œuvre
de des principes de la loi et notamment
l'inscription et l'orientation au 1er
janvier 2025 et accompagner la montée en
charge des des pilotes sur
l'accompagnement rénové du RSA puisque
les départements engagés souhaitent pour
un certain nombre d'entre eux ont la
maturité suffisante pour augmenter le
nombre de bassins d'emploi couvert et on
a aussi un certain nombre de
départements assez nombreux je dois dire
qui sont volontaires pour pouvoir euh
s'engager aussi dans la démarche sur le
le le le service aux entreprises c'est
un enjeu clé et et je dois dire que
c'était d'ailleurs un enjeu qui était
absent effectivement comme vous l'avez
dit du projet de loi non pas absent de
la philosophie de France travail mais du
du projet de loi et je salue euh le
travail que vous avez mené c'est c'est
aussi madame gruni qui qui qui l'avait
mentionné de de de bien ajouter cette
cet élément parce que c'est sur deux
pieds en fait que fonctionne la bataille
de l'emploi évidemment l'accompagnement
des services aux entreprises est aussi
important pour Paul emploi et pour les
acteurs du du réseau pour l'emploi que
l'accompagnement des des demandeurs
d'emploi dans ces priorités là il y a
et la mise en place justement de de ces
protocoles en fait de préfiguration avec
les régions c'est d'organiser le faire
équipe aussi la coopération entre les
acteurs économiques pour pouvoir
prospecter les entreprises main dans la
main avec les chambres de commerce et
d'industrie avec les chambres des
métiers et d'artisanat mais aussi avec
les branches professionnelles parce
qu'au-delà des 5700 conseillers
entreprises de Pô emploi il y en a aussi
parfois dans les plis dans les maisons
de l'emploi dans les dans les
conseillers enfin dans les missions
locales et puis il y a aussi 4000
conseiller par exemple dans les branches
professionnelles porté par les OPCO et
l'idée c'est que on fasse équipe pour
s'assurer qu'on prospecte beaucoup plus
d'entreprises et qu'on les accompagne et
qu'on leur apporte les meilleurs
services car si les services de Pole
Emploi se sont grandement améliorés en
direction des les entreprises ces
dernières années on est passé de l'ordre
de 50 % de satisfaction à 83 % de
satisfaction pour les entreprises qui
utilisent les services de de P emploi il
est vrai que les entreprises et
notamment les plus petites euh ne sont
pas sont encore trop nombreuses à ne pas
bénéficier des services proposés par ple
emploi de l'ordre de 25 % pour les
petites entreprises quand les grandes
entreprises eux recourent largement au
service de Pôle Emploi donc ça c'est les
priorités l'accessibilité notamment pour
les TP PME et puis dernier point c'est
le rapprochement euh entre ple emploi et
et et Cap emploi et et je dois avouer
que ce ce ce rapprochement a été aussi
une source d'inspiration pour la
réflexion sur sur sur France travail et
on voit bien que euh plutôt que de faire
une fusion et bien ce rapprochement
c'était plutôt de jouer de la meilleure
des complémentarités entre Cap emploi et
et et poôle emploi euh ce que j'ai en
tête c'est d'abord le le retour et la
satisfaction des des des personnes hein
plus je je pourrais vous redonner
exactement les chiffres mais je je crois
que que les personnes qui sont
accompagnées on est à plus de 80 % de de
niveau de satisfaction des personnes sur
la prise en charge par cet
accompagnement ple emploi Cap emploi
plus de 90 % des conseillers de ple
emploi disent avoir augmenté leur
compétences et leur aptitude à pouvoir
accompagner ou faire face aux situations
de difficulté de santé ou de handicap
lié à leur montée en compétence par le
développement de l'interconnaissance et
du partage de connaissances avec les
conseillers spécialisés de de Cap emploi
et puis la mise en place du lieu unique
d'accompagnement c'est aussi une
inspiration pour France travail c'est
que quand on travaille aussi et qu'on
partage aussi des lieux en fait on
développe aussi cette interconnaissance
qui nous permet d'adresser de façon plus
personnalisée les situations des uns et
des autres et c'est donc une inspiration
qu'on
pourra sur laquelle on pourra s'appuyer
le le le dernier point peut-être c'est
que du coup fort de ce de ce bilan il
faut qu'on aille plus loin et c'est
d'ailleurs le fruit des propositions qui
sont sorties de de la Conférence
nationale du handicap et dont neuf des
dispositions vont pouvoir se mettre en
application suite au
vote de la loi et notamment le fait que
France travaille ce soit d'abord une
approche de droit commun et que on mette
en place et on va tester dès 2024 avec
les acteurs du handicap et les maisons
de les maisons de les
MDPH la capacité à pouvoir orienter les
personnes quelle que soit leur situation
je pense notamment aux situations les
plus complexes par exemple les jeunes
qui sortent duulis ou ou de ou ou
d'ime merci beaucoup pour vos réponse je
donne tout de suite la parole à Frédéric
puissard
oui merci Monsieur le le président
d'abord dire à à Tibau guili que j'avais
eu l'occasion de travailler avec lui
dans le cadre du du PCT d'ambition pour
l'IAE et que j'avais apprécié à la fois
sa capacité à fédérer des acteurs qui
sont pas toujours simples à fédérer du
reste et sa capacité à trouver des
réponses pragmatiques aux solutions qui
qui étaient proposées qui relevaient pas
toujours du du législatif d'ailleurs euh
et souligner aussi que nous avons eu
avec Jean Basser et et vous l'avez dit
hein saluer le travail qui a été fait
toujours un discours de de vérité et de
franchise et et c'est ce que nous
attendons d'un directeur de de Pôle
emploi de France travail demain euh avec
les relations qu'il peut avoir avec le
Parlement et notamment le le Sénat deux
questions euh la première sur le nombre
d'équivalent en plein euh à Pôle Emploi
actuellement euh on a été plusieurs à
noter qu'en 5 ans les effectifs de de
Pôle Emploi avaient progressé de 10 %
alors c'est vrai que on peut considérer
que c'est pas assez on peut
considérer un certain nombre de choses
de part et d'autre en tout cas nous ce
qu'on perçoit quand même au sein de la
majorité c'est qu'il y a eu quand même
certes un élargissement des prérogatives
de Pôle emploi il y a eu les sèges qui
sont arrivés il y a eu effectivement une
attention particulière portée au milieu
économique mais d'abord on a un enjeu
qui est de savoir si demain on sera en
capacité de déployer la la réforme qui
va s'annoncer avec le nombre d'emplois
nécessaires alors on en a créé 300 c'est
vrai euh en 2024 sans financement je le
rappelle quand même hein puisqu'il y a
pas eu de progression du financement
pour pour l'emploi pour ces 300 emplois
et puis il y a un relica qui reste de la
crise sanitaire d'un certain nombre
d'emplois donc ce que nous demandons
nous c'est une évaluation du nombre de
TP àemploi donc première question est-ce
que vous comptez conduire cette
évaluation est-ce que vous considérez
que vous avez le nombre d'agents
suffisants pour conduire la réforme à
venir 2ème question le financement de de
Pôle emploi et notamment la la
contribution de l'Unedic à Pôle emploi
je rappelle qu'elle a longtemps était de
10 % que sans l'accord des partenaires
sociaux est passé de 10 à 11 % et que le
gouvernement espéré par l'accord
national interprofessionnel qui s'est
conclu il y a peu de temps l'a passé de
11 à 12 à 13 %. or elle est restée à 12
% dans l'accord national
interprofessionnel est-ce que vous
considérez que ces 11 % sont suffisants
et notamment pour mener la réforme venir
pour passer de Pôle Emploi à France
travail merci beaucoup et je donne
maintenant la parole à Pascal gruni qui
était rapporteur du projet de loi pour
le plein emploi oui merci Monsieur le le
président et merci Monsieur monsieur
guilouis pour votre première
intervention alors tout d'abord moi je
j'avais une une première question
concernant le contrat d'engagement qui
doit définir les 15hures hebdomadaires
d'activité donc vous en aviez parlé dans
votre rapport de de préfiguration après
le gouvernement ne souhaitait pas et
donc vous suiviez bien entendu le
gouvernement il ne souhaitait pas
l'inscrire dans le texte de de loi qui
finalement a été inscrit à notre
initiative donc là cont tenu des
premières expérimentations qui ont qui
ont été qui ont été fait est-ce que vous
pouvez nous nous dire un petit peu
comment ces 15 heures ont été mises en
place les difficultés qui sont
rencontrées de part et d'autres parce
que c'est un un contrat donc à la fois
du point de vue des des des demandeurs
d'emploi et puis à la fois aussi de tous
ceux qui qui accompagnent et puis donner
un peu les des des exemples en fait sur
sur ces retours d'expérience et
d'expérimentation
ensuite lors de l'examen de la loi pour
le plein emploi nous avons veillé à ce
que le réseau pour l'emploi permette à
tous les acteurs de de travailler
ensemble sur le terrain de mettre en
commun leurs moyens tout en respectant
les prérogatives de de chacun je pense
notamment aux collectivités
territoriales aux missions locales bien
entendu alors selon vous quelle devra
être la place de l'opérateur France
travail au sein du réseau pour l'emploi
et comment l'opérateur va-t-il se
positionner dans la prise de décision en
particulier vis-à-vis des collectivités
territoriales vous savez que c'est ça
faisait partie des des désaccord et et
tout du moins on a modifié d'ailleurs le
texte de loi pour qu'il y ait pas de
recentralisation et pour qu'il ait bien
une une
coordination claire et et bien précise
pas de corde de rappel enfin on a
vraiment mis ça donc moi j'attend euh de
de vous que vous nous rassuriez sur sur
ça parce que euh vous voyez vous êtes
est allé il y a pas longtemps chez moi
et le retour en fait que que j'ai eu y
compris de personnes dont je suis très
étonnée en fait ils ont senti que vous
étiez assez le maître de la situation et
pas du tout dans dans l'écoute c'est un
ressenti je n'étais pas présente mais je
voulais vous le dire parce que je n'ai
même pas demandé parce que je savais pas
que vous alliez chez moi et et j'ai eu
comme ils savent que j'étais rapporteur
voilà voilà ce ce qu'ils m'ont dit et je
vous assure que une des personne ça m'a
vraiment étonné donc je pense qu'il faut
qu'il faut faire attention et d'ailleurs
parce que même là dans votre discours
j'ai pas beaucoup entendu le réseau pour
l'emploi vous savez bien que c'était un
sujet c'est-à-dire que France travaille
qui devait être à la fois le nom du
réseau à la fois le nom de l'opérateur
on en a discuté beaucoup finalement j'ai
cédé à ce que l'opérateur s'appelle
France travail mais dans les médias dans
la bouche des ministres dans la bouche
des représentants de l'État ça reste
France travail et et ça ça sincèrement
vous savez bien que c'est ce qui a
crispé beaucoup beaucoup les missions
locales y compris aussi l'organigramme
que vous aviez mis dans dans le document
de de préfiguration dans lequel
finalement Paul emploi était au-dessus
la mission locale et Cap emploi et
franchement si on veut réussir c'est
être ensemble côte à côte et de et de
travailler vraiment sans qu'il y ait un
poids Paul emploi devenu l'opérateur
France travail bien entendu sera là pour
les appuis parce que a une connaissance
importante il y a aussi tout tous les
comment les services informatiques et
cetera donc ça va être déjà je dirais
voilà quand même à la tête de de de
toutes les informations enfin la majeure
partie des informations mais s'il y a
pas les bons échanges si les agents
aussi travaillent pas correctement ils
se sentent eux investi d'un certain
pouvoir ça fonctionnera pas et
l'objectif on le partage tous
c'est-à-dire dire de ramener les gens
vers vers l'emploi donc moi je veux que
vous me rassuriez sur sur cette bonne
coordination sur cette capacité d'écoute
et et sur le respect en fait du texte de
loi qui a été voté et et d'insister sur
le réseau pour l'emploi France travail
c'est l'opérateur ça juste un changement
de de nom pour l'opérateur mais ça n'est
pas le réseau vous merci merci Madame la
rapporteur monsieur monsieur guidoui je
vous laisse répondre
à ces questions
euh alors sur sur les sur les questions
sur les sur sur les moyens d'abord je
pense que ce qui est vraiment important
de pas perdre et d'ailleurs c'est c'est
en rebond avec peut-être la
préoccupation sur le réseau pour
l'emploi c'est que on parle beaucoup des
ETP de P emploi mais moi je regarde
d'abord les 160000 professionnels de
l'accompagnement qui existent et qui
sont un pôle emploi mais qui sont aussi
dans les missions locales dans les Cap
emploi dans les associations d'insertion
dans les dans les dans les dans les
départements dans les euh dans le
secteur de de de l'hébergement et et de
l'insertion ils sont 30000 aussi
là-dessus et que du coup le
l'accompagnement et le défi pour
s'assurer qu'il y ait personne au bord
de la route et queil y a un
accompagnement personnalisé doit se
construire euh en ayant bien en tête
cette diversité et cette capacité
d'intervention de l'ensemble de ces
acteurs et surtout pas de ple emploi ce
qui je sais pas si je pourraz vous
rassurer parce que derrière la confiance
c'est quelque chose qui se construit et
donc c'est probablement aussi par les
actes que ça ça ça ça pourra se se
démontrer mais que pour essayer de
répondre à la à la question sur sur les
300 les 300 ETTP de 2024 je dirais que à
ce stade pour 2024 et sur la montée en
en puissance ça nous ça nous permet de
le ça nous permet de le faire il faudra
évidemment avoir des discussions sur
2025 2026 et 2027 mais qui seront aussi
éclairés par la capacité à mettre en
œuvre ses accompagnements et s'appuyer
d'abord sur les forces en
présence sur chacun des territoires et
chaque territoire n'est pas doté
toujours de de la même manière et c'est
là où il faut qu'on soit attentif à
cette approche un peu différentiée du
sujet le sur la question sur sur sur
l'accord unéque écoutez moi la la
trajectoire c'est celle qui qui m'a été
enfin que j'ai que j'ai rappelé suite à
la question de de de Monsieur mou après
le financement de l'opétion se fait
effectivement par l'Unedic et par l'État
principalement il y a aussi un peu de
FSE un petit peu d'autrre chose mais
c'est principalement ça et que ce qui
n'est pas financé par l'Unedic et et du
coup dans la trajectoire pluriannuelle
financé financé par par l'État cela
étant dit on a les discussions de du
renouvellement de la convention
tripartite avec tunedic et qui peut être
l'occasion d'une discussion aussi sur le
rapport qu'attendent les partenaires
sociaux au sein de lunedic entre
les services et les impacts réalisés
pour les demandeurs d'emploi et pour les
entreprises et les moyens qui le
mobilise pour cela donc on peut aussi
dans cette logique un peu
d'investissement social avoir des des
débats assez constructifs dans les dans
les mois et les années qui viennent sur
sur sur alors sur le retour sur les 15
he alors il y a peut-être un premier
retour quand même parce que la
philosophie c'est quand même celle du
contrat d'engagement jeune qu'on a lancé
en en mars 2022 avec Elizabeth bne on a
signé récemment le 500000e contrat
d'engagement jeune donc on commence à
avoir un certain retour quand même
là-dessus et les difficultés qu'il a pu
y avoir sur la montée en puissance des
15h ben chaque mois qui passe là on est
à peu près à 20h en moyenne par exemple
sur sur Pole Emploi simplement moi les
15h ou les 20h ou les 25h faut pas en
faire un un un alpha ou un Oméga
l'objectif c'est bien d'avoir
l'accompagnement adapté qui permet le
retour à l'emploi des personnes mais
pourquoi ça monte en puissance et qu'on
a débuté à 11h et qu'on est maintenant à
20h en moyenne sur pole emploi c'est
parce que en fait le développement des
coopérations le fait que on partage
l'offre de service avec les missions
locales avec les acteurs du territoire
qu'on innove qu'on regarde un petit peu
de plus en plus le on a fait franchement
le comité des parties prenantes le le on
a un comité de suivi où il y avait aussi
les écoles de la deuxème chance les épil
ou et cetera et par rapport à y a par
rapport au derniers de il y a 6 mois
honnêtement on peut reprendre les
minutes du comité des parties prenantes
mais côté Mission Locale P emploi E2C
làdessus c'était assez assez positif ça
veut pas dire qu'on a pas encore des
défis devant nous je pense notamment au
service CIVI qu'on peut encore améliorer
mettre en visibilité un certain nombre
de services sur les territoire le la
place des immersions et du rôle des
entreprises de l'implication des
entreprises dans le cadre des contrats
d'engagement jeune on progresse mais on
est encore on y est pas encore sur ça
donc on a aussi tout un tas d'axes de
progrès et on a ensemble ble avec les
parties prenantes valider de façon assez
unanime une feuille de route pour les
axes de progrès sur la mise en œuvre de
ces 15 ou 20heur sur le le RSA c'est un
peu la même mécanique à part qu'on n pas
un le même recul que les modalités de
mise en œuvre sont évidemment différent
entre des bénéficiaires du RSA dans les
situations sont très différentes des
jeunes qui enfin de de qui peuvent être
très différentes des jeunes ça dépend
d'un territoire à un autre on a
évidemment le sujet aussi de l'offre sur
C un territoire où c'est plus compliqué
on le voit bien dans la ruralité par
exemple pour le contrat d'engagement
jeune et donc on anticipe aussi un petit
peu ça et c'est là où il faut aussi
qu'on a une capacité à avoir un effort
différencié en fonction de ce qu'on
constate de la disponibilité des
solutions sur sur sur le territoire
typiquement sur la mobilité on a lancé
là dans la perspective de France travail
moi j'ai lancé dans trois communautés de
communes par exemple la question de la
mobilité qui était un des sujets sur
lequels vous nous avez beaucoup
d'ailleurs sensibilisé dans dans les
débats euh pour accompagner un certain
nombre de communautés de commune avoir
une vraie stratégie d'accompagnement à
la mobilité avec des moyens associés
pour voir comment on peut résoudre cette
équation là faire le test voir ce que ça
suppose et ensuite créer les conditions
de sa montée en puissance progressive et
sa généralisation si jamais les
résultats sont sont probants d'où la
d'où la trajectoire budgétaire qui est
qui est qui est montante
euh le le point alors sur les couches je
prends le point euh tends si si l'écoute
je pense que c'est la clé en fait pour
que ça marche donc à chaque fois que
quelqu'un a le sentiment de pas se
sentir écouter c'est un problème parce
que si je mesure l'ampleur de la tâche
je suis aussi puisque je vais beaucoup
sur les territoires assez confiant parce
qu'en fait quand on est sur le terrain
il y a une énergie et il y a des gens
qui ont envie de faire qui est hyper
importante et ce qui est important c'est
que les gens se sentent écoutés
considérés et connectés pour que ça
puisse fonctionner et donc évid
évidemment que je dois tout
particulièrement montrer l'exemple et
que donc à chaque fois que je ferai
preuve d'un sentiment de manque d'écoute
ou et cetera bah je tâcherai de
continuer de travailler sur moi-même
pour pouvoir le corriger heureusement
ils sont pas tous à le dire hein mais
mais j'ai j'ai j'ai une marche de
progression et je prends le je je prends
le point sur le réseau pour l'emploi et
sur France travail et et et très
probablement que j'ai pas su forcément
toujours bien expliquer la la la la
philosophie de la démarche peut-être et
il faut dire aussi quand même que on est
quand même sur un environnement et sur
un écosystème qui est quand même
particulièrement compliqué mais
l'opérateur est un opérateur donc ceux
qui font et et et Paul emploi demain
France travail tout comme les missions
locales Cap emploi et les associations
sont là pour faire mettre en œuvre la
gouvernance politique stratégique et
financière elle est assurée et je n'ai
jamais rien dit d'autre rien n'écrit
d'autre que les décisions sont prises
par ceux qui assurent cette gouvernance
les contractualisations d'ailleurs se
font par l'État et par les les
collectivités en revanche si on a un
découplage trop fort et c'est ce que
j'observe dans certains territoires il y
a des territoires qui fonctionne très
très bien parce que entre ceux qui ass
sur la gouvernance politique
c'est-à-dire les élus locaux et l'État
je rajoute les partenaires sociaux dans
le quadripartisme notamment à l'tion
régionale et et nationale même s'ils
peuvent aussi intervenir localement il y
a aucun problème mais cette gouvernance
là ne peut pas bien fonctionner si quand
on appuie sur le bouton n'est pas
connecté aux opérateurs et donc France
travaille c'est aussi la logique de
territorialiser au niveau des bassins
d'emploi l'action concrète et les moyens
de PUL emploi mais les moyens qu'on met
pour les missions locales et pour les
autres acteurs doivent bien être au
service des décisions qui sont prises
localement par les services de l'État de
façon concomitante avec les
collectivités c'est vraiment ça qu'on a
envie de faire et donc le réseau pour
l'emploi le le le réseau pour l'emploi
c'est c'est là que ça se passe c'est
dans ces comités locaux et donc on va
apprendre ensemble on on on va apprendre
parce qu'on a les expérimentations RSA
avec les départements mais ou les
régions et les élus les maires je je je
commence à en rencontrer aussi beaucoup
parce que les Mair doivent être beaucoup
mieux pris en compte beaucoup mieux à la
manœuvre sur la bataille de l'emploi ils
ont déjà des outils ad hoc qui
fonctionnent bien avec les missions
locales avec un peu les plis les maisons
de l'emploi mais là ce qu'on propose
c'est d'aller plus loin en faisant en
sorte queil y ait une vue d'ensemble sur
l'ensemble des demandeurs d'emploi et
l'ensemble des enjeux de l'entreprise
donc c'est de passer un cap là-dessus et
donc c'est vraiment ça la philosophie en
tout cas qu'on envie de porter merci
beaucoup alors vous êtes 13 à avoir
demandé la parole donc je vous
demanderai simplement d'être un petit
peu concis et je vais commencer par
l'amburgois
oui pardon monsieur le Président
Monsieur j'aimerais vous vous interroger
sur quelle place et quelle stratégie
vous souhaiteriez mettre en place pour P
emploi dans nos quartiers j'allais dire
politique de la ville j'étis pendant 13
ans adjoint la politique de la ville
d'une commune 150000 habitants avec un
quartier de 17000 habitants euh avec un
taux de chômage dans ce quartier-là en
voisinant les 30 % et malheureusement
pas d'agence de Pole emploi dans ce
quartier-là malgré les demandes euh du
maire ENF actuel pô emploi a ouvert une
agence à 2 ou 3 kilm en dehors de ce
quartier-là euh pas du tout facile
d'accès euh pour pour les pour les
habitants donc c'est vrai que c'est une
demande forte on sait que dans ces
quartiers il y a un taux de chômage
beaucoup plus
élevé que dans d'autres secteurs et
notamment dans des milieux plus urbains
voire en ruralité même s'il y a aussi de
la précarité et du chômage dans ces
quartiers-là et l'autre question à vous
poser c'est par rapport toujours par
rapport à ces quartiers vous savez que
les quartiers qui font qui bénéficient
des projets de rénovation urbaine
importants avec dans ce cadre là des
clauses d'insertion
social par rapport au montant de ces de
ces travaux quelle place là aussi pour
pa emploi pour
inciter non pas les entreprises mais il
faut faire de la pédagogie aussi pa
emploi pour inciter les entreprises à à
insérer à et à bénéficier de de ces
clauses d'insertion sociale qui sont
indispensable si on veut j'is dire
redonner un certain espoir dans certains
quartiers
merci beaucoup Monique Lubin
oui monsieur le Président alors chaque
fois que nous avons une
une une réforme comme ça on entend
toujours des choses très intéressantes
des superlatifs ça sera forcément mieux
qu'avant moi depuis qu'on parle de
l'arrivée de France travail je cherche
la différence et donc j'aimerais qu'en 3
qu mots vous puissiez nous dire quelle
est la plusvalue de France travail sur
po emploi première question deuxème
question sur les fameuses 15h
aujourd'hui les les personnes qui sont
au RSA depuis un moment sont les
personnes les plus éloignées de l'emploi
qui cumulent un grand nombre de
difficultés donc moi je voudrais savoir
comment vous allez pouvoir mettre en
place cet accompagnement sachant quand
même
que je ne suis pas la seule ici je
préside encore mensuellement une
commission RSA et il y a donc un certain
nombre de bénéficiaires du RSA qui sont
orientés vers Pôle emploi et qui ont
déjà un accompagnement donc je voudrais
savoir qu'est-ce qui va être fait en
plus et comment vous allez pouvoir
tisser un réseau d'entreprises qui
accueilleront des bénéficiaires du RSA
plutôt âgé pour un certain nombre parce
que vous faites la comparaison avec avec
le le le dispositif pour les jeunes qui
était précédé de la garantie jeune qui
avait elle aussi très très bien marché
j'ai j'étais à l'époque présidente de
mission locale comme d'autres ici
j'imagine on sait aussi que quand même
ça commence un petit peu à sessouffler
et que l'engagement des entreprises moi
je vois sur mon département qui était
très très important au début ça commence
un petit peu à s'essouffler donc comment
allez-vous faire pour créer ce réseau et
qu'est-ce qui va être fait en plus que
ce qui est déjà fait par les agents de
poil emploi et trisème et dernière
question et non la moindre je voudrait
avoir votre vision des choses sur une
éventuelle réduction de l'indemnisation
des chôeurs de plus de 55 ans très bien
la parole Olivier néo merci monsieur le
Président merci Monsieur guiloui pour
votre exposé assez complet voire très
complet alors on connaît votre
engagement pour l'économie sociale on
voit que vous maîtrisez votre sujet
c'est pas la la question principale ma
question concerne plutôt la question de
la gouvernance vous y avez répondu et
notamment vous avez été interpellé par
ma collègue et notamment la capacité à à
créer de la collégialité et de la
connexion parce que sans ça ça marchera
pas la connexion avec les entreprises
avec les partenaires sociaux dans leur
ensemble et avec les territoires avec
les régions les métropoles et les
départements au fond je vais vous dire
en toute sincérité que le le le doute il
est là sur la la capacité non pas sur
votre capacité votre connaissance du
dossier mais votre capacité à créer
cette collégialité je vous remercie très
bien la parole à Justin guidez
oui merci Monsieur le le Président j'ai
eu l'occasion lundi de visiter une
grosse entreprise il y avait la mission
locale et puis Paul emploi qui était
présent et on a pu s'apercevoir que
l'inclusion au sein de cette entreprise
était plutôt particulièrement
absente alors je pense pas que ce soit
un manque de volonté mais plutôt comment
dire un problème de savoir-faire voilà
c'est de se dire comment on peut
euh inclure une personne handicapée au
sein de l'entreprise euh en respectant
bien sûr tout ce qui peut être sécurité
alors moi je voulais savoir si vous
pouvez accompagner les entreprises sur
ce genre de de sujet et vous avez parlé
des aidents mais très rapidement euh il
y a une loi qui existe c'est de comment
dire le temps de travail au sein de
l'entreprise une adaptation donc du
temps de
travail comment faire respecter déjà la
loi parce qu'aujourd'hui les entreprises
ne respectent pas cette loi làà donc
c'est pas tout de faire des lois donc
j'en suis dépositaire de cette loi si en
fin de compte elle n'est pas respectée
donc je vois pas comment on peut avancer
sur ce genre de sujet et comment
reconnaître aussi les dents dans dans
l'entreprise puisque généralement il se
fait pas connaître donc comment à la
recherche justement de de l'dans dans
dans l'entreprise alors comment
pensez-vous mettre ce genre de chose en
place merci merci beaucoup Émilienne
pomérol
oui pardon merci monsieur le Président
mes questions vont rejoindre ça vous
étonnera pas celle de de Monique Lubin
puisque vous êtes à l'origine monsieur
du texte que nous avons combattu sur le
sur le plein emploi puisquil il procède
pour nous d'une logique pardon vous me
voyez pas je vais me tourner d'une
logique adéquationnelle je dirais entre
des gens qui sont au RSA et qui sont
culpabilisé parce que comme si c'était
de leur faute alors que c'est aussi un
échec de de ple emploi et des des postes
vacans et qui suffit de les mettre face
à face pour que pour que ça fonctionne
avec en plus une idée de sanction qui ne
va faire selon nous agraver la la
précarisation donc ma première question
porte un petit peu sur le problème du
financement et sur le problème des du
nombre d'emplois à PUL emploi puisque
PUL emploi va avoir tous les inscrits et
va donc avoir beaucoup plus de de cas à
traiter et donc comment vont-ils arriver
et en particulier aussi la formation des
des agents de ple emploi puisque il va
falloir qu'il soit davantage formé pour
voir les les techniques d'insertion je
rappelle que les départements et les
missions locales avaient cette mission
et donc ma deuxième question sur à part
celle du financement et du nombre
d'emplois rejoint pour une fois nous
sommes d'accord avec enfin pas pour une
fois mais celle de avec Pascal grunny
sur sur le réseau parce que quoi que
vous en disiez on a l'impression et le
sentiment que c'est Paul emploi qui va
chapauter et être le grand chef et que
les autres vont venir demander la
permission de faire quelque chose sans
avoir et donc quelle est vraiment la
réalité de de la j'allais dire de la
coordination de l'ensemble des acteurs
qui Contin continu à vouloir à vouloir
participer et et une question aussi sur
un nouveau terme que je viens d'entendre
dans votre
présentation que va être l'Académie
France travail encore un nouveau terme
encore est-ce que c'est un nouveau
gadget c'est quoi l'Académie France
travail merci la parole à Corine
Ferret merci monsieur le Président au
risque d'être
répétitive je je je souhaite non
seulement vous poser une ou deux
questions mais aussi réaffirmer redire
que au moment où cette réforme se projet
de loi a été examiné débattu ici dans
l'hémicycle nous nous nous notre groupe
euh politique a été fortement opposé et
nous avons voté contre alors aujourd'hui
vous êtes devant nous pour après avoir
porté ou initié ou suggérer cette
réforme vous êtes devant nous pour vous
présenter en tant que candidat aux
fonctions de directeur général futur
directeur général de pôul emploi ou
France travail pour autant euh donc ce
vote et cette approche négative de notre
part euh m'amène à vous poser
effectivement des questions concrètes et
aussi parce qu'H nous avons évoqué et
débattu sur la mission budgétaire
travail emploi donc le lien il est très
direct je veux revenir sur les moyens
attribués à à Pô emploi ou France
travail demain dans ce budget 2024 mes
collègues l'ont dit
euh 300 emplois ou 300 équivalents temp
plein sont programmés nous considérons
que cela est insuffisant par rapport aux
enjeux qui attendent demain même pas
après-demain mais demain euh France
travail ple emploi 31 ETP sur
53000 salariés donc voilà ça fait
0,0 et cetera c'est pas beaucoup sur
vous avez et vous serez à la tête de
responsabilité de plus de 900 agences et
relé de proximité parce que c'est bien
là aussi me semble-t-il euh le but
d'être en proximité avec celle et ceux
qui sont en recherche d'emploi donc vous
ramenez vous faites un petit ratio avec
300 collaborateurs supplémentaires ça me
semble ça nous semble nettement
insuffisant tout comme les moyens dédiés
encore une fois à cette cette réforme de
de de France travail vous l'avez rappelé
c'est ce que vous aviez évoqué dans
votre rapport un coût de 2 milillard 3 à
2 milliard 7 d'ici à 2026 mais n'oubliez
pas de de rappeler aussi que les
départements dans leur ensemble nous
avaient tous alerté en disant on est
très très très en DIN de du coût ou des
moyens qui seront nécessaires pour cette
nouvelle façon d'accompagner les
demandeur d'emploi et particulièrement
le fait d'une inscription obligatoire
pour les bénéficiaires de RSA ce sont 2
millions de personnes qui vont être
normalement en lien avec pô emploi
France travail donc on est très en DESS
ça des
moyens nécessaires et et attendu donc
au-delà de je sais pas si je peux vous
poser la question puisque vous serez euh
vous postuz en tout cas pour être futur
directeur général mais au-delà de la
nouvelle ponction ou la ponction
supplémentaire qui sera faite sur
l'Unedic sur les recettes de l'Unedic on
a eu débat déjà d'alerter certes
l'Unedic est en excédent depuis cette
année l'année passée mais n'oublions pas
les dettes qui sont très importantes et
le plan de désendattement qui était
engagé une édique organisme ou
organisation paritaire donc là aussi le
dialogue social don dont on parlait tout
à l'heure il est essentiel à respecter
vous avez évoqué le le le travail que
France trava que France travaille i
ferait euh sur le versement des
allocations chômage bien évidemment je
je ne vous ferai pas je n'aurai pas la
déessence de vous rappeler qu'avec la
réforme de l'assurance chômage les
choses ont bougé les choses ont évolué
que euh de nombreux hommes et femmes
vont se retrouver sans assurance sans
indemnité euh du fait des nouvelles
règles et sans parler comme M dit comme
l'a dit euh ma collègue de ce qui
pourrait être envisagé pour les plus de
55 ans donc ce que vous souhaitez mettre
en œuvre pouvez-vous nous le préciser un
peu plus et enfin une dernière question
relevant du réseau euh France travail
mes collègues sont intervenu sur euh en
vous demandant quel serait le rôle et la
place euh dans ce réseau pourô l'emploi
mon réseau France travail et moi je
voudrais euh bien sûr m'associer à cette
question mais en vous demandant très
précisément euh comment ou pensez-vous
qu'il serait possible d'intégrer ou de
réintégrer dans ce réseau la gfip la
gfip qui s'attendait très je dirais
naturellement ou très légitimement à
être dans ce dans ce réseau être dans la
gouvernance nationale et qui a été entre
guillemets excusez-moi sorti euh de
cette organisation à sa très grande
surprise et évidemment euh à ce très
grand
regret merci beaucoup oph
Romani merci beaucoup alors je ne serai
pas très longue parce qu'on est nombreux
vous avez bien compris dans notre
échange de regard que je partageis
largement les inquiétudes de ma collègue
Pascal grunny vous y avez du coup
partiellement répondu enfin rpondu
répondu à quelques inquiétudes pour ma
part je serais effectivement vigilante à
la place d'émissions locales dans dans
dans ce dans ce réseau et
particulièrement euh en ruralité je
voulais savoir comment est-ce que vous
allez vous avez parlé du hallz vert donc
effectivement mais concrètement le Halet
vert j'aimerais savoir ce que vous
comptez mettre en place parce
qu'aujourd'hui euh pour
l'inscription de Pôle Emploi vous vous
servez de France service et des bus et
cetera en ruralité c'est bien le suivi
maintenant
euh connaî quelques défaillances en
ruralité donc on a quand même des freins
périphériques vous vous y avez Avaz fait
allusion donc je sais que vous y serez
attentif mais voilà il y a un point de
vigilence à apporter et notamment on a
parlé du du seège lorsque Paul emploi a
été contacté pour le sège euh plus vite
que les missions locales ça n'a pas
donné un signal très positif en tout cas
aux missions locales dans leur place
qu'elles avaient euh au sein de au sein
de ce réseau euh ce grand réseau pour
l'emploi et je pense que peut-être que
les inquiétudes sont nées d'ici aussi
euh parce que c'est le moment où on
commençait à parler de France travail et
et les signaux envoyés ont été négatif
donc je compte vraiment sur vous euh
demain euh pour garder cette place
importante à l'insertion des jeunes euh
crédau des des missions locales très
bien monsieur guili je demande déjà je
propose de réponre à cette première
série de d'intervention et nous
passerons ensuite à la 2è 2e série
à la limite je vais commencer par euh
cette interpellation puisqu'elle
reboucle avec avec celle qui avait
commencé avec avec votre collègue juste
sur lesémission locales bon d'abord moi
j'ai commencé j'ai lancé ma première
structure
d'insertion en en lisant et en déclinant
le rapport de Bertrand Schwarz et donc
la notion d'accompagnement global
personnalisé et la place des missions
locales dans
l'écosystème ça fait 25 ans que je
travaille avec elle je vois pas pourquoi
je commenceraiis à les mettre en en
difficulté mais plus actuellement
au-delà de de ma petite histoire
personnelle avec avec l'émission locale
l'All vert vous avez vous avez raison je
vais vous prendre deux exemples sur
lequel parce que il se trouve que la
coconstruction en fait que ce soit du
rapport mais même de la mise en œuvre se
fait avec l'Union nationale d'émissions
local qui d'ailleurs avait salué le
rapport ensuite à discutter sur le sur
les modalités de mise en œuvre du projet
de loi et on travaille ensemble je vais
vous donner deux trois exemples un sur
l'allé vert on sait que une bonne partie
des des jeunes dans notre pays qui sont
en échec et en difficulté et qui
atterrissent ensuite sur une prise en
charge d'émissions local c'est des
jeunes qui sont qui sortent par exemple
des lycées professionnels aujourd'hui on
a mis en place avenir pro et c'est pas
l'emploi qui s'occupe d'avenir pro
c'està-dire de l'accompagnement des
jeunes lycéens professionnels sur les 6
derniers mois avant leur sorti pour
éviter qu'on les perde et de pouvoir les
accompagner dans leur premier stage dans
leur premier emploi et bien une des
propositions que j'ai faite aux missions
locales et que nous allons mettre en
œuvre dès 2024 c'est que il me semble
que compte tenu de la nature de ces
jeunes et bien qu'on fasse équipe et
qu'on s'appuie beaucoup plus fortement
et beaucoup plus largement sur le réseau
d'émission local pour pouvoir mettre en
œuvre ce type d'accompagnement et sortir
de cette exclusivité de Pole Emploi
deuxième exemple si vous savez il faut
de de l'amour mais aussi des Pres
d'amour si je comprends bien le deuxième
exemple c'est les universités c'est
aussi un autre enjeu où quand même on a
euh les les les jeunes qui arrivent en
université est-ce que l'échec scolaire
et l'échec étudiant il est pas lié au
niveau des personnes il est lié à
l'orientation subit et aux difficultés
sociales et familiales qui peuvent être
autour et donc les jeunes qui arrivent à
l'université il y en a un sur deux qui
ne passe pas qui ne passe pas la la le
cap même j'ai envie de de dire de des
vacances des vacances de Noël et donc
travailler ensemble quand je dis France
le France travail et lesmions locales
avec les universités et je fais une
prentation devant tous les présidents
d'université il y a une quinzaine de
jours mais ça on va le faire main dans
la main avec les missions locales pour
pouvoir proposer un parcours
d'orientation et de réorientation pour
éviter cet échec étudiant et travailler
main dans la main et décloisonner en
fait le monde universitaire avec le
monde de l'insertion professionnelle ça
procède de la même logique je pourrais
vous dire on travaille avec laaz et avec
les départements on a des sujets comme
cela évidemment sur tous les jeunes qui
sont en grande difficulté ça sera plutôt
s'appuyer sur les missions locales en
tout cas fortement sur les missions
locales mais il y a aussi les écoles de
la deuxième chance les épis les les
autres acteurs qui peuvent être des des
contributeurs évidemment autour de de de
ce noyau dur euh euh les les
implantations euh dans mon rapport j'ai
mis France travail à 5 km euh de chez
soi ça fait un peu sourire mais ça
répond aussi un petit peu à la question
de que vous euh que vous disiez si on
n'est pas en proximité de ceux qui en
ont besoin l'accessibilité au service
public ne fonctionne pas alors vous avez
raison euh Paul emploi a déjà euh 896
agences euh quelques relais euh donc
vous aviez raison de dire plus plus 900
et elle s'appuie sur les 2000 et
quelques Frans service mais les missions
local c'est 7000 implantations partout
sur le territoire et notamment là-dessus
un des autres objets de discussion mais
je ne veux pas préempter les décisions
qui vont qui vont se faire mais pour
vous dire en tout cas la nature du
partenariat euh moi je suis très ouvert
à ce qu'en fait les personnes qui
arrivent en en mission locale quand je
dis le 5 km on va pas réouvrir des
nouvelles agences France travail par
contre faire équipe avec les autres
acteurs du réseau pour l'emploi pour
qu'en fait on amène le meilleur des
services si on se met un petit peu lieu
unique d'accompagnement si on partage un
petit peu et qu'on travaille un petit
peu mieux ensemble là-dessus donc ça ça
fait partie des sujets sur lequels
l'Union nationale desémions locales a
fait part de son intérêt à à travailler
à travailler dessus je sais pas si ça
lèvera toutes vos inquiétudes et et et
et vos impressions mais j'espère que au
fur et à mesure on va pouvoir les lever
euh les euh sur la question du coup des
des des quartiers prioritaires de la
ville monsieur euh c'est c'est un des
enjeux clés alors il y a des déjà des
choses qui ont été faites je reviendrai
pas sur le sur le programme équipe
emploi et et les moyens un petit peu
supplémentaires qui ont été faits mais
concrètement il y a une inégalité il y a
une inégalité de d'accès à l'emploi
notamment lié au phénomène de
discrimination lié au non lié à
l'adresse lié aux opportunités
économiques qui sont proposées et donc
évidemment c'est un vrai défi que de
mieux accompagner les les les personnes
en qpv donc on a le sujet de comment on
amène le service plutôt en proximité et
donc là il y a vraiment et clairement et
dans les et dans les et dans les
quartiers là où il y a besoin il faut
qu'on amène le service public là où il y
a besoin donc on travaillera sur sur sur
ce sujet là il y a aussi de de continuer
cette philosophie qui a mis en place
Jean Basser c'est faire plus pour ceux
qui en ont le plus besoin et que du coup
les les les moyens soient plus forts
vous avez mentionné aussi la question
des des des entreprises al d'abord les
clauses sociales il se trouve que les
clauses sociales on a travaillé ensemble
euh à la faveur du de la loi climat et
résilience pour renforcer considération
sociale là-dessus mais comme il y a pas
que la loi mais queil y a aussi
accompagné les conditions de la loi euh
j'avais coélaboré le plan national des
achats durables on a mis en place un
réseau de 500 facilitateurs de Claus
notamment avec le réseau ave euh et euh
on a mis aussi euh on a mobiliser les
entreprises le fameux réseau les
entreprises s'engagent là les 70000 et
bien il y a un programme pour qu'elle
s'engage beaucoup plus auprès des des
quartiers et dans les clauses sociales
concrètement quand même entre 2022 et
2023 les clauses sociales sont passées
de 22 à 33 % donc on est en phase de
progrès et on continuera évidemment
d'agir euh d'agir dans ce dans ce sens
euh voilà sur sur donc l'engagement des
entreprises il y a eu plusieurs
questions qui ont été posées sur à la
fois l'engagement des entreprises il
faut un d'abord le stimuler c'était euh
le c'est le sens de la démarche de la
communauté les entreprises s'engagent
mais effectivement après derailleè c'est
une question de compétences et donc on
développe et on a fait des propositions
et on va développer des formations
pour recruter des personnes en situation
de handicap pour développer son approche
inclusive on a pour ça lancé un campus
de l'inclusion qui propose des
formations qui réussissent très bien au
TPE au PME pour développer leurs
pratiques inclusives ça il faut que on
change d'échelle et qu'on multiplie en
fait cette montée en compétence il y a
beaucoup d'entreprises qui sont prêtes à
s'engager mais qui ne savent pas comment
le faire et il faut les accompagner et
ensuite la deuxième chose c'est
simplifier parce que les solutions des
entreprises vous prenez par exemple un
outil désolé de rentrer dans le concret
mais un outil qui marche très bien c'est
l'immersion dans l'entreprise pouvoir
faire une journée une semaine un mois
dans une entreprise pour valider un
projet professionnel pour sortir des
stéréotypes de recrutement on en fait un
petit peu moins de 200000 à pôul emploi
ça s'appelle la pmsmp et bien avec
France travaille avec les équipes de Pô
emploi depuis un an d'abord on a changé
ce pmsmp ça fait fuir tout le monde
personne ne comprend les acronymes donc
ça s'appelle l'immersion là où il
fallait passer par un SERFA où ça
preneait plusieurs semaines avec des
charges administratives maintenant vous
pouvez vous y accéder sur votre y
compris sur votre smartphone et et vous
verrez aussi les statistiques parce que
le pilotage par les résultats c'est
aussi la transparence des résultats et
vous verrez département par département
si vous le souhaitez en accès libre la
montée en puissance de ces immersions et
bien quand les entreprises on leur
facilite la vie et ben vous verrez que
les immersions on était à 25 en début
d'année on est déjà à 150 ou 170000 euh
euh euh à à date là-dessus et vous
pouvez le le contrôler mais il en faut
pas 170000 il en faudra 300000 400000
500000 peut-être un million demain et
c'est pour ça qu'il faut stimuler
l'engagement et faciliter l'engagement
des entreprises y compris pour pouvoir
accompagner les 15 heur dont madame
Gruny vous me vous me challengez un
petit peu sur sur cette sur sur ce
sujetl le le point euh le point sur la
collégialité sur la gouvernance dont
vous avez fait part et et vous m'avez
partagé vos doutes
mais vos doutes je les partage euh euh
parce que c'est pas simple non mais ça
serait de de de dire que de dire que
c'est de dire que c'est simple de mettre
de de de se dire on se met d'accord sur
un objectif donc se mettre d'accord sur
un objectif ça veut dire d'abord
partager les données aujourd'hui il y a
pas un seul maire en France qui connaît
et et qui a accès aux informations enfin
maire ou président de communauté de cun
mais ce qui est vrai pour les maires et
vrai aussi pour un président de
département ou un préfet d'ailleurs on
ne connaît pas où sont les personnes qui
sont sans emploi ou éloigné de l'emploi
parce que évidemment il y a un peu les
fichiers de P emploi pour autant qu'ils
y aient accès on a les bénéficiaires du
RSA on a les jeunes et donc d'abord la
première des choses c'est de partager
avec les élus et avec les services de
l'État les les personnes et quels sont
leurs besoins là-dessus donc ça c'est ce
qu'on a commencé à faire avec les
expérimentations dans les départements
dans les départements et que nous allons
prolongé et déployer dans les
gouvernances locales et dans les comités
locaux la deuxième des choses c'est que
une fois qu'on connaît les demandeurs
d'emploi et les entreprises il faut
qu'on puisse prendre des décisions et
certains
m'ont parlé de l'accompagnement oui mais
il y a la garde d'enfants oui mais il y
a le logement oui mais mais c'est
exactement ça la philosophie de France
travail c'est qu'on n'est pas dans un
adéquationnisme et que pour accompagner
quelqu'un et ben on peut pas accompagner
à un moment donné l'emploi et un autre
moment le logement ou la garde d'enfants
c'est de façon concomitante et c'est là
où c'est le réseau pour l'emploi et
qu'on on ne peut travailler que en
réseau là-dessus mais pour ça il suffit
pas juste de mettre les gens autour de
la table parce que ça ça a déjà été fait
moi ça fait 20 ans que je suis dans
l'insertion et que je vois aussi on
appelle à se mettre autour de la table
mais il faut aussi après d'ailleurs
donner les outils pour passer à l'action
donc c'est un les données et la prise de
décision où le maire bah lui il a
peut-être parfois les moyens par exemple
sur la garde d'enfants pour créer une
des places en crèche à VIP supplémenta
avec le maire et le département mais si
la région elle ne veille pas à ce que
son offre de formation est accessible ou
adapté à des personnes soit en situation
d'édance ou de handicap donc il faut pas
du temps plein mais il faut du temps
partiel ça ne marche pas et donc ces
comités locaux c'est un un seul comité
là o aujourd'hui il y en a quatre ou
cinq c'est-à-dire une gouvernance unique
et simplifié et où le maire le président
de département ou son représentant la
Région et l'État sont ensemble pour
faire un peu pot commun pour atteindre
l'objectif qui est choisi et comme j'ai
des doutes monsieur ho et ben en fait je
ne crois qu'à une chose c'est à la mise
en place en bonne intelligence sur les
territoires et comme il se trouve qu'il
y a déjà des territoires qui le font
d'ailleurs c'est comment on accompagne
ces bassins d'emploi on va les outiller
on travaille avec eux pour les outiller
pour discuter avec les maires les élus
les et mettre en place dans les semaines
qui viennent dans les mois qui viennent
apprendre de ce mode de fonctionnement
pour se dire de quoi on a besoin
ensemble pour qu'au niveau des bassins
d'emploi on puisse mieux mener cette
bataille pour le pour le plein emploi et
c'est pour ça aussi que je pense que ça
c'est typiquement un sujet ce qu' ça
sera intéressant de revenir régulière
enfin de revenir régulièrement pour voir
les apprentissages qu'on a fait et
comment on peut progresser ensemble sur
cette réelle gouvernance simplifiée
opérationnelle du réseau pour l'emploi
euh voilà pour les principales alors
vous avez parlé de formation de
l'Académie francera c'est c'est
franchement c'est pas nouveau hein c'est
c'est c'est dans le rapport et en fait
cette cette Académie et on peut
l'appeler autrement c'est pas le c'est
pas le sujet mais le sujet c'est que il
faut développer l'interconnaissance un
je n'ai jamais vu et en 20 ans de
pratique et ça n'existe pas un chargé
d'insertion sociale et professionnel qui
connaît toutes les solutions c'est pas
possible parce que entre l'accès au
droit le logement la connaissance la
connaissance des systèmes très complexes
de formation d'emploi de santé et donc
ce qui est important c'est que ça
travaille ensemble et qu'on développe
l'interconnaissance pour que le
travailleur social du département puisse
faire le premier kilomètre de l'emploi
en passant en pouvant s'appuyer sur sur
sur l'opérateur qui va savoir le faire
si si un conseil Mission Locale
rencontre une problématique
d'hébergement qui puisse se connecter au
travailleur social du centre
d'hébergement d'urgence ou au Centre
d'hébergement de réinsertion sociale
là-dessus et donc développer cette
interconnaissance elle est absolument
clé pour qu'on gagne en efficacité c'est
ça l'objectif de l'Académie France
travail merci beaucoup la parole à
califé
qualifé merci monsieur le Président je
voulais vous remercier Monsieur pour
votre présentation et saluer comme vous
l'avez fait le travail de Jean Basser
que j'ai eu le plaisir de côtoyer un peu
au moiselle ou pour revenir sur ce que
vous venez de dire à l'instant
euh la coordination est importante j'ai
eu le plaisir de le faire durant un
mandat qui se termine au niveau du
département de la miselle où on a fédéré
effectivement l'ensemble des acteurs
état pô emploi et association euh en
finançant aussi des associations qui
étaient les facilitateurs pour chacun
des territoires et ça se passe plutôt
bien on a pu diminuer d'une façon
significative le nombre de RSA sur notre
territoire puce qu'on en a sur 1 million
d'habitants 25000 à peu près personnes
qui relèvent du RSA euh ma ma question
aujourd'hui est d'actualité on en a
parlé déjà ce matin est-ce que vous avez
prévu dans vos réflexions euh une
plateforme
spécifique pour euh aider les étudiants
qui le souhaitent à trouver un travail
adapté et compatible avec leur
scolarité merci beaucoup la parole à
vivan my
oui merci monsieur le Président euh
monsieur guli merci pour votre exposé
alors moi je vais vous amener à la
Réunion département que vous avez visité
depuis alors depuis le le la
recentralisation du RSA et malgré
compéten légales en matière d'insertion
et d'accompagnement de tous les
bénéficiaires du RSA le département de
la réunion n'a plus accès à l'ensemble
des données utille à la prise en charge
de ce public l'expérimentation France
travail en est directement impactée
l'absence d'échange et d'actualisation
et vous en avez parlé des données rend
particulièrement complexes
l'identification la mobilisation et
l'accompagnement même du public concerné
en outre à ce jour cette situation ne
permet pas de disposer des données
consolidées indispensable au ptittage de
l'expérimentation quelle disposition
pouvez-vous prendre pour remédier à
cette situation sur notre département
alors 2ème question la loi prévoit que
le gouvernement dispose d'un délai de 6
mois à compter de l'adaptation de la loi
pour prendre les ordonnances
d'adaptation du texte au contexte
spécifique des
outremèes les travaux relatif à
l'ordonnance n'ont pas commencé quel est
le calendrier prévu et quelles sont les
modités de concertation avec les
collectivités locales dans ce cadre
comment comptez-vous prendre en compte
les résultats de l'expérimentation du
département de la réunion de même les
crédits liés à la levée des freins à
l'insertion pour être pourront
être mobilisés pour accompagner la
dynamique d'encouragement à la reprise
d'activité engagé par le département de
La Réunion dans le cadre du dispositif
R+ que vous connaissez très bien merci
pour vos réponses merci beaucoup la la
parole à
mariean
merci monsieur le Président bonjour
Monsieur Merci pour votre présentation
alors moi je vous ramène à une île plus
proche l'île de France après ma collègue
Vivian mé voilà on est on aura pas un
grand déplacement à faire parce que nous
nous posons les mêmes problématiques je
pense que toutes les région se pose les
mêmes problématiques celle de la
compatibilité de la coordination des
systèmes d'information pour le pilotage
le plus efficient possible des
dispositif de tous les acteurs du champ
de l'emploi la formation professionnelle
bien sûr ensuite une petite
question très opérationnelle et
d'actualité Pôle Emploi est sûrement le
premier opérateur de l'État avec je
crois
55000 équivalent en plein on est dans la
séquence des recherches d'économie
est-ce que vous êtes déjà projeté parce
que vous serez sûrement sollicité à ce
titre sur des perspectives de recherche
d'économie étant entendu que là vous
allez avoir un supplément de de postees
pour pouvoir mener à bien l'installation
de de la future du futur opérateur
est-ce que vous vous avez vous êtes déjà
projeté sur cette perspective euh un
autre sujet qui concerne le contrôle de
la recherche d'emploi c'est sûrement un
sujet qui est lacunaire dans notre
système en France euh est-ce que vous
avez prévu euh des dispositifs
spécifiques ou des moyens spécifique
dans un contexte de marché du travail
dynamique et enfin le sujet de la
gouvernance qui est revenu à plusieurs
reprises qui est important euh parce que
vous êtes revenu sur le l'association
notamment des régions alors c'est très
intéressé parce que je suis encore pour
quelques mois vice-président de la
Région î-de-france chargé de l'emploi et
la formation et donc j'ai lu le rapport
de préfiguration avec beaucoup d'intérêt
où la région nécessité que deux ou trois
fois alors que la région est un euh un
opérateur et euh la collectivité
historique compétente en matière
d'emploi et de formation donc comment ce
pilotage vous allez l'organiser en
mettant la région à sa place puisque
j'ai cru comprendre que vous souhaitiez
travailler avec toutes les collectivités
et on fait une question un peu
malicieuse est-ce que vous pouvez est-ce
que vous envisagez est-ce que vous
seriez favorable à une
expérimentation associant plus
étroitement la région à un conseil
d'administration qui serait piloté par
la région une espèce d'expérimentation
territoriale sur le pilotage
localement de l'opérateur avec un un une
présidence par la région de cette
administration de cette de ce conseil
très bien merci beaucoup rayond
pourong merci monsieur le Président
alors Monsieur Gul vous avez été
l'architecte de de France travail
l'inspirateur je dirais de la loi plein
emploi euh puisque vous êtes à l'écoute
j'espère que vous avez regarder les
critiques de ceux qui ont été contre les
écologistes et le reste de de de la
gauche alors de ce fait c'est c'est vrai
vous êtes le meilleur candidat enfin
vous avez créé votre fich de poste et
vous êtes le meilleur candidat pour
l'appliquer euh donc il faudra qu'on
sache si euh on valide l'inspirateur de
la loi plein emploi ou si on valide le
fait que vous êtes ê très certainement
le meilleur à répondre à cette fiche de
poste
euh moi je voudrais peut-être venir sur
l'expérimentation sur les
18 territoires qui sont
expérimentés pour ce qui est par exemple
de la métropole de Lyon c'est vrai que
nous appliquons quand même le fait que
le contrat d'engagement est réciproque
même si ça a été refusé de mettre
réciproque et que il est d'abord pour
les les les territoires qu'
l'exérimentent l'engagement d'un
accompagnement renforcé et adapté des
personnes avant d'appliquer peut-être
les suspensions
mobilisation il faut avoir
d'abord des enfin on a d'abord des
droits avant d'avoir des devoirs et C il
faudra bien que vous vous vous regardiez
cet élément là et l'expérimentation vous
parlez beaucoup du contrat d'engagement
jeune l'expérimentation elle se juge non
pas dans les 500 premiers ça dansni
jeais c'estàd que on peut très bien vous
vous en doutez quand même sélectionempo
est un peu accusé de de ça d'ailleurs
d'avoir sélectionné ceux qui étaient le
plus à même de de sortir du dispositif
c'est peut-être un
reproche faux mais moi je l'ai entendu
mais ça sera jugé quand comme le
territoire zéro chômeur vous vous
occuperez des RSA qui ont 45 à 50 ans 50
chômage derrière eux minimum et et 25 %
en situation d'handicap c'est là qu'on
jugera et qu'on évaluera votre
proposition moi je reviens sur le fait
que c'est une question ça que je veux
vous porter sur le fait que vous
préconisez un portefeuille de 60
loocataires par par conseiller je
rappelle que c'était déjà la promesse de
la fusion à NPE àdque et j'aimerais
savoir si vous avez quand même et
d'ailleurs le plein emploi aussi était
la promesse de la précédente fusion euh
quel bilan critique vous avez fait ça en
quoi vous avez pour faire votre propre
proposition tenu compte du fait que vos
prédécesseurs avaient fait la les mêmes
promesses et qu' les avaiit pas tenu
donc elles ont été les freins pour ça
donc d'autant plus que vous préconisez
l'inscription de tous les RSA comme
demandeur d'emploi de fait de facto donc
euh moi j'aimerais connaître non pas
votre votre trajectoire d'embauche parce
qu'on dit 300 est-ce que c'est plus
est-ce que c'est moins c'est pas ça la
question c'est quelle est votre
projection pour arriver dans le temps
qui vous est réparti à 60 à loocataire
par conseiller j'ai bien entendu que
désormais pour calculer ce 60 àocataire
vous allez prendre les conseillers qui
sont un peu de partout mais moi c'est
c'est pas tant que vous les prenez à
émission locale tout ça ça me pose pas
de souci mais j'aimerais savoir quelle
place vous allez donner aux organismes
de de placement privés parce que ces
organismes de placement privé ont été
très développés et pour avoir ces 60
allocataires moi j'ai bien l'impression
que ça sera le recours le recours
principal alors je le pose d'autant plus
la question que les analyses ont été
faites que
c'est organismes de placement privé sont
moins efficients que l'accompagnement
public donc ça c'est la première
question
etou alors très vite ensuite puisque
vous allez inscrire tout le monde et que
vous voulez le plein emploi 5 %
j'aimerais savoir est-ce que vous allez
changer les catégories de Pôle emploi
c'est-à-dire est-ce qu'on va avoir à
part les AB C D le F les RSA que vous
arrivez pas à placer parce que sans
changement changer les catégories je
vois pas trop comment vous allez y
arriver sauf à radier de façon massive
donc et ensuite et pour
finir je suis tenté de dire que vous
avez parlé des partenaires sociaux que
vous avez mis en national et en régional
mais quand nous avons demandé qu'il soit
aussi en département et local le
ministre nous a dit que il connaissait
pas les partenaires sociaux au niveau
départemental donc ça m'inquiète un peu
même au niveau local donc quelle place
vous donnez aux partenaires sociaux au
plus près puisque vous êtes dans
l'expérimentation au plus
près sur les quatre niveaux au niveau
départemental et local voilà merci
beaucoup Catherine concon oui merci le
président ce sera rapide euh monsieur le
futur potentiel directeur général euh
vous êtes appelé à faire la révolution
dans cette maison j'espère que cette
révolution ne s'arrêtera pas uniquement
au changement de nom nouveaux concept et
Cera euh Paul emploi donne l'impression
d'une grosse machine d'un gros mamouth
pour ne plager aucune autre
administration euh avec une efficacité
tout à fait relative en tout cas c'est
le v V que j'ai et le vécu je suis de la
Martinique le vécu que beaucoup de chefs
d'entreprise et beaucoup d'usagers ont
du Pô emploi beaucoup de monde beaucoup
de moyens déployés beaucoup de budget
certainement mais une transparence somme
tout relative sur l'efficacité et le
fait que les mesures mises en place et
les résultats soient percutant ça c'est
la première chose donc j'espère qu'on
sera dans une organisation aujourdhi
extrêmement moderne qui passera par des
enquêtes d'évaluation régulières fait de
manière beaucoup plus générale que ce
qui se fait aujourd'hui aussi bien
auprès des chefs d'entreprise qui me
disent régulièrement avoir plus
d'efficacité quant à leur recrutement en
passant par des cabinets de recrutement
plutôt que pour l'emploi mais également
auprès des des demandeurs d'emploi qui
sont notre première cible donc on attend
cette révolution paemploi c'est un
acteur important on a bien dit
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
salariés un gros budget de l'État le
référent de l'État dans beaucoup de
domaines donc j'attends que vous
puissiez nous dire quels sont les moyens
qui vont être mis à la disposition d'une
vraie révolution dans l'institution
merci Laurence
mbô merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le
Directeur moi je voudrais revenir sur
l'emploi des seniors je crois que ça a
été posé la question mais j'ai pas
entendu la réponse alors dans le cadre
du projet pleinant emploi l'État semble
avoir les seiors dans le viseur et Bruno
Le Maire a évoqué la possibilité de
réduire la durée d'indemnisation
spécifique au demandeurs d'emploi de
plus de 55 ans pour l'amener au même
niveau que celle des autres catégories
de demandeurs d'emploi or on sait qu'en
France un employé est aujourd'hui
considéré comme senior dès l'âge de 45
ans sa productivité n'est plus forcément
considérée comme suffisante alors en
dehors des questions du deuil d'un
emploi où le salarié c'est souvent
investi depuis de nombreuses années on
sait qu'il sera difficile de retrouver
un emploi il y a quelques années un
dispositif avait été mis en place pour
inciter les employeurs à recruter des
personnes en fin de carrière auxquels il
manquait quelques trimestres avec le
recul de l'âge de départ à la retraite
on risque de se retrouver avec des
demandeurs d'emploi âgé de 60 ans et
plus euh comment envisagez-vous de créer
une attractivité autour de ces prof F
plutôt fatigué plutôt blessé
plutôt avec des difficultés nouvelles et
comment allez-vous faciliter leur retour
à un emploi stable sans dévalorisation
de leurs compétences et expérience autre
question une sanction intermédiaire est
introduite en ce qui concerne le
bénéfice des prestations monétaires et
des service d'accompagnement vous avez
parlé d'un contrat d'engagement et là il
y a donc une sanction intermé qui serait
introduite la suspension de
remobilisation comptez-vous mettre en
place un service de coaching pour
booster le moral et les candidatures
puisque quelquefois c'est un peu
difficile de se remettre à l'emploi pour
plein plein de raisons et comptez-vous
uniquement app vous appuyez sur la peur
d'une sanction pour atteindre cet emploi
comment envisagez-vous cela enfin dans
le projet France travail il est question
de de de lien avec les entreprises et
chaque entreprise pourra disposer d'un
interlocuteur privilégié dans le cadre
d'une offre de service commune alors là
aussi dans les agence un service dédié
aux entreprises existe déjà ce sont des
conseillers qui sont en charge de
l'accompagnement des entreprises depuis
la prise de l'offre jusqu'au recrutement
final recomtez-vous décentraliser les
décisions pour permettre aux agences une
plus grande adaptabilité aux réalités du
terrain urbain rural suivant les les les
établissements scolaires et de formation
qui sont à proximité et offrir un
service couumain merci Monsieur le
Directeur très bien et la dernière
intervention et ensuite nous nous
écouterons monsieur qui pour la réponse
madame
nadille oui merci monsieur le Président
alors Monsieur gully moi j'aurai deux
questions très brèves alors moi je viens
de la Guadeloupe la circonscription de
la Guadeloupe et moi j'ai une question
que pensez-vous de la précarité de
l'emploi chez les conseiller à l'emploi
chez Paul emploi euh nous avons un
turnover à peu près de 40 % donc
beaucoup de CDD donc ça ne permet pas
euh d'accompagner des demandeurs
d'emploi sur le long terme et
donc je pense que les chiffres sont
faussés donc d'abord sur les CDD et de P
emploi 2è question le dispositif de
l'accompagnement global le partenariat
qui est fait avec la collectivité
départementale et le Pôle emploi euh il
a été recruté h assistants de servicees
social qui sont déployés dans les
agences j'aimerais savoir est-ce que
vous avez un retour au bout d'un an et
enfin 3ème question le dispositif aVIP
qui ce sont les crèches à voocation
insertion professionnelle qui a été
déployé en Guadeloupe en mars 2023
est-ce que vous avez un retour et est-ce
que c'est positif voilà merci voilà
monsieur guiloui je vous propose une
réponse en 6 minutes pour arriver à un
compon parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
questions et là on pourrait passer que
toute la journée et ensuite nous allons
passer au vote
euh du coup pour essayer d'être
exhaustif en 6 minutes les aidents c'est
dans le texte on va le prendre en compte
en tout cas madame pour les demandeurs
d'emploi la prise en compte des des
aidants dans l'accompagnement des
demandeurs d'emploi et aussi on fait des
travaux avec un certain nombre d'acteurs
pour valoriser aussi les les expériences
et les compétences des aidants donc là
c'est c'est un sujet en tout cas qui est
qui est clair Clement pris dans dans
dans France travail et un très gros
enjeu agfip j'avais pas répondu
mais en tout cas le le travail avec
lagfip sur la mise en œuvre de toutes
les mesures CNH ils seront associés au
comité technique à la gouvernance France
travail à chaque fois que leur
contribution peut-être apporté je crois
queil y a des échanges aussi qui qui ont
lieu entre les les sénateurs et laagfip
récemment euh
sur
la euh la tac tac tac oui plateforme
étudiant pour pour la moiselle ben j'en
profite enfin sur ce sujet là il y a la
plateforme un jeun une solution il y a
quand même 14000 c'est là pour le coup
c'est moi qui le le le le le plaisir de
la mettre en œuvre et typiquement pour
pouvoir apporter les bonnes solutions à
chaque jeune en fonction de leur
situation plus 14 millions
d'utilisateurs et c'est quelque chose
sur lequel on va continuer d'investir
sur sur les mois et et années qui
viennent stage job étudiant accès à
l'emploi apprentissage enfin apporter
les les bonnes solutions aux bonnes
personnes sur la la question de de
madame la sénatrice de la Guadeloupe
alors d'abord sur les conseillers emploi
ça je pense quef il y avit aussi un peu
des questionnements là-dessus quand même
il y a a il y a plus de 50000 CDI pour
5000 CDD le turnover le turnover sur
tout pour emploi alors peut-être après
j'ai pas été regardé sur les chiffres de
la Guadeloupe mais à 5,1 % ce qui si on
enfin si si toutes les entreprises
étaient à ce niveau de turnover enfin
donc à mon avis je pense qu'en terme de
stabilité là-dessus on est est-ce que on
peut encore améliorer les choses bien
sûr je dis pas ça hein mais on parle pas
d'une
situation catastrophique le dialogue
social fonctionne bien il y a eu 36
accords qui ont été signés depuis 2019
il y a eu les élections récemment
là-dessus et donc est-ce que il faut
l'attention à la QVT aussi enfin le ces
sujetsl sont pris en il y a un dialogue
social qui fonctionne bien évidemment il
faut être extrêmement attentif à le
consolider à le renforcer pour améliorer
ses situations et après faire le
traitement peut-être plus ponctuel sur
un territoire ou sur un autre et là je
prends le point mais on regardera on
regardera dans un autre cas
l'accomagnement global bah typiquement
c'est les résultats on pourra vous les
les partager mais typiquement
accompagnement global c'est quelque
chose qui produit tellement de enfin des
bons résultats parce que c'est
travailleurs sociaux et cons pas
l'emploi qui agissent ensemble pour
accompagner personnes les plus éloignées
et c'est ce qu'on est en train du coup
de déployer sur sur sur France travail
merci de mettre euh le le point sur les
crèches àip he qui dont le nombre de
places a fortement augmenté je voudrais
pas me hasarder dans le chiffre exact
que j'en ai un mais mais c'est quand
même plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
de places àip qui ont été créées il faut
continuer parce que la question de garde
d'enfants pour l'accès à l'emploi est
absolument majeure donc les retours sont
très bon maintenant est-ce que ça répond
à l'entièreté des besoins euh il me
semble que non et que il faut qu'on
continue cette montée en puissance
extrêmement favorable qui est portée
depuis quelques années euh euh avec le
gouvernement et les collectivités euh
sur la Réunion euh alors les données CAF
mais ce qui est vrai pour la Réunion et
j'échange énormément avec les équipes à
la Réunion là-dessus mais est vrai dans
tous les départements et donc on a
engagé un chantier j'ai eu un échange
avec le directeur général de la CAF
encore récemment pour faire en sorte que
l'accès aux données CAF soit possible
pour tous les départements de France et
ça ça sera débouclé d'ici le 1er janvier
2025 au plus tard y compris parce que
quand on demande 30 ou 40 fois un
bénéficiaire du RSA de justifier qu'il
est au RSA on lui fait perdre son temps
on fait perdre le temps des trailleurs
sociaux et en plus de ça on n même pas
sûr de la réponse donc donc en tout cas
ça et et sur le calendrier des
outremères on vous le passera mais on a
déjà commencé à à à discuter de de ça
pour pouvoir adapter de bien prendre en
compte les spécificités quand même liées
aux outremèes dans la mise en en œuvre
et d'ailles le président de la Réunion
m'avait et la présidente aussi m'avait
bien sensibilisé sur l'adaptation des
des des des outils il me reste même pas
une minute là ou 2 minutes de euh euh
système
d'inf financement pour une aide
financière pour le r ça je je je reviens
avec vous on euh euh
ouais système système système
d'information système d'information
plateforme il y a énormément de
énormément d'investissements qui sont
prévus pour pouvoir et et d'outils qui
sont déjà qui ont déjà commencé à être
développés avec les départements mais on
a aussi l'enjeu avec les régions et avec
les villes pour avoir un si plateforme
et de l'interconnexion des données donc
ça c'est très engagé avec pas mal
d'investissement et ça c'est un un sujet
majeur évidemment y compris pour que les
collectivités puissent avoir accès après
d'ailleurs à toutes à toutes ces données
l'efficience mais bien sûr que dès qu'on
pilote une organisation il faut
réfléchir à son efficience et je je nous
savons que on passe aussi par exemple
beaucoup de temps sur le reporting et
que le travail sur sur les outils nous
permettrait d'automatiser un certain
nombre de tâches pour en consacrer un
petit peu plus à la relation et au
service qui est d'ailleurs ce qui motive
le travail des conseillers et qui
parfois aussi les démotive ou les
décourage quand on voit la charge
administrative qui peut y avoir
là-dessus euh euh sur les seniors
puisque vous avez sur les seniors on
partage complètement moi j'ai je vais
pas me prononcer sur la question de
l'indemnisation en tout cas ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que la réalité
c'est que aujourd'hui les personnes
seniores c'est c le taux de chômage des
personnes senior est plus faible mais
quand on mais quand on regarde quand on
est au chômage à plus de 50 ou 55 ans
les durées au chômage sont deux fois
plus importants pour un certain nombre
de points sur lequels vous vous avez
pointé le pointé le doigt donc ça
suppose mais on partage donc on partage
mais complètement on est on est
complètement d'accord sur le diagnostic
ensuite après derilleurs c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on peut mettre en œuvre il y a à la
fois les négociations qui ont été
engagées avec les partenaires sociaux
que je peux pas préempter mais il y a
aussi tout un tas d'actions que ce soit
la destination des entreprises sur les
pratiques euh sur les pratiques
accompagner la reconversion adapter
l'offre de formation aussi aux personnes
seniores développer la validation des
acquis de l'expérience il y a un certain
nombre de choses qui sont proposé dans
les 99 propositions qui sont de nature
en tout cas à essayer d'améliorer la
situation et mais le chantier est aussi
devant nous et merci de m'avoir euh
enfin voilà remis le point sur un sujet
sur lequel je suis particulièrement
sensible euh bien évidemment euh dans
euh le le coaching c'est pas la question
de la peur des sanctions la question
d'abord c'est l'accompagnement et
d'ailleurs sur les portefeuilles à à 50
à 60 c'est que quand on est en
difficulté et quand on doit faire un
accompagnement personnalisé global ça ne
fonctionne pas si on a plus de 40 50 60
personnes à suivre ça c'est la réalité
concrète alors maintenant ça renvoie à
la question des moyens sur lequel vous
m'interrogez mais cette question des
moyens moi quand je discute avec les
départements euh et et bien y compris
d'ailleurs dans l'INE parce que là pour
le coup j'avais écouté la
vice-présidente de l'INE et à partir du
moment où l'accompagnement on le
renforce ce choc de l'insertion et que
du coup ça fait baisser le nombre de
bénéficiaires du RSA ça dégage des
marges de manœuvre sur lequels les
départements avec l'État sont prêts à en
redéployer sur l'insertion parce que les
moyens aujourd'hui on en met 15
milliards et principalement sur
l'allocation parce que on ne s'occupe
pas des bénéficiires du RSA si on les
aide à se réinsérer ça dégage des marges
de manœuvre aussi pour cela merci
[Musique]
beaucoup je si vous écoutiez vous
vousz pas j'ai demandé d'avoires les
réponsse par écrit parce que mes trois
questions ont pas été
répondu c'est bon c'est bon donc moi ce
que je vous propose monsieur
guou grand je vous propose monsieur
guiloui c'est qu'on puisse avoir un
certain nombre de réponses par écrit des
sujets qui n'ont pas été évoqués ce
matin je vous remercie on va procéder
nous à la suite des opérations parce
qu'on a encore un petit peu de temps de
vote merci beaucoup en tout
cas merci à vous
effectivement je suis navré pour les
questions auquelles ça pas été répondu
mais je suis prêt à y répondre
aujourd'hui et demain par écrit je suis
à votre disposition merci beaucoup pour
cet exercice à bientôt pardon mes chers
collègues